the one thing you got to give so much
credit to the left is they understood if
you want to control the way people think
go control universities okay yeah you
got to do that but by the way
Republicans were lazy on it that's true
they have one school which is what
Hillsdale and he maybe got a couple
other Christian schools that you got you
know Bible schools that you got what
else do the Republic even even Duke
nowadays is what is on the left yeah
Duke is not the Duke of 30 years ago
yeah Harvard so so so with the
Republicans rather than taking the money
that they had and creating some real
universities they just said no I'm gonna
go out there and just do my business
stuff that's what I'm going to be doing
so I think that part is a mistake of the
right you know like right now the left
is losing their minds because Elon Musk
bought Twitter why because they've been
controlling media for how long now God
knows how long that's strategically a
good move on them so Elon comes in he
starts exposing everything and like yeah
Twitter files don't even talk about it
on mainstream media they're scared
shitless that's how you compete